Sometimes the best parts in a movie
aren't in the script from impromptu
slips to unexpected explosions these
sci-fi movie bloopers were just too good
to leave out
the first Guardians of the Galaxy film
capture audiences with its endearing
take on the universe showcasing quirky
aliens colorful worlds and lighthearted
Adventure the movie expanded the Marvel
Cinematic Universe into the far reaches
of space at the center of the story is
Peter Quill charmingly portrayed by
Chris Pratt quill has come into the
possession of one of the most powerful
weapons in the Galaxy an orb that
audiences would later discover holds one
of the six Infinity Stones the sought
after high-priced orb has an array of
people hunting for it including thanos's
followers in The Collector played by
Benicio del Toro while Krill and his
Newfound acquaintances do their best to
protect the powerful artifact the
blundering protagonist comes close to
Breaking the treasure after discovering
the orb's value importance and fragility
quilt fumbles and drops the artifact as
the deal is made to sell it to the
collector it is an iconic moment that
defines Chris Pratt's clumsy character
and surprisingly it was not in the
script according to director James Gunn
Pratt's fumble was unexpected and
incidental yet the filmmaker loved it so
much it had to make the film's Final Cut
Martian is a wonderful movie about
science prevailing in the face of
adversity based on a novel by Andy Weir
the story follows astronaut Mark Whitney
played by Matt Damon Whitney is
inadvertently abandoned on Mars and
forced to survive in an Extended Stay
while awaiting a rescue mission from
NASA although he exceeds expectations
while living in the alien atmosphere
things do not go so well back on Earth
admits failed rocket launches costly
bureaucracy and time limits scientists
on Whitney's home planet do what they
can to bring him back one of the
Geniuses who comes up with a plan to
rescue Watney is The Eccentric Rich
Purnell played by Donald Glover among
strange traits like sleeping in his
office and talking erratically to
himself a defining moment for the
characters when he trips on his own feet
and quickly recalibrates himself
hilariously Glover admitted during an
interview on Conan that the fall was an
honest mishap when you see me in the
movie and I eat it that's really eating
it yeah however the moment still appears
in the movie the first Star Wars movie
is undeniably considered a classic but
loved by fans the world over A New Hope
launched one of the biggest franchises
the world has ever seen But although
Star Wars Episode 4 is considered
perfect by many moviegoers standards the
film was not without its mistakes one of
the funniest blunders in Star Wars takes
place in the Galaxy's most dangerous
weapon the Death Star One Stormtrooper
can be seen knocking his head on top of
a door as the Imperial Army descends on
R2D2 and C-3PO in the control room
although the upward sliding doors make
the Death Star appear futuristic the
bump showcases how flawed these entrance
ways and low visual helmets would be in
the real world somehow Landing in the
Final Cut of the film The stormtrooper's
Doorway miscalculation is one of the
most famous bloopers to appear in a
movie
there are times when directors actively
try to capture the perfect blooper to
get the most genuine reaction from the
performers as possible one of the best
examples of this trickery comes in
director Ridley Scott's 1979 space
horror alien Scott made many notable
choices that helped make alien the smash
hit that it is including choosing a
female heroine over a standard male
action star well fans of alien may be
surprised to know that one of the
movie's most famous moments involved a
nasty surprise for the entire crew of
the Nostromo in his book Cinema
Alchemist the film's art director Roger
Christian explained the momentous scene
where the newborn alien explodes from
the chest of Officer Kane Christian
wrote Ridley did not want the actress to
see the setup just to experience the
horror of the moment the baby alien
actually breaks through so when the
alien violently protrudes from Kane the
reactions you see on the actors are all
genuine meanwhile the blood-covered look
of shock on their faces remained in the
film
when the original Blade Runner was
released in 1982 he'd redefined what
science fiction could look like in
cinema yet another film on this list
directed by Ridley Scott the story is an
adaptation of Philip K Dick's novel
through Android's Dream of Electric
Sheep featuring a dystopian future
plagued with synthetic replicants the
movie follows hardened God brick Deckard
as he hunts down the advanced robots and
uncovers dark secrets about the company
that made them one of the futuristic
replicants that Deckard has been
assigned to retire is press who is
performed by 80s film darling Daryl
Hannah unfortunately the young actress
took such a spill that she needed
medical attention in one scene a panic's
press is seen tripping and falling into
a car window however the temple was
unintentional as the window was not
supposed to break as a result of the
accident the actress had broken her
elbow in eight places thankfully Hannah
was able to finish the scene with no one
the wiser and her fall made it into the
Final Cut of the film
the Back to the Future Trilogy is a
beloved take on one of science Fiction's
favorite themes time travel starring
Michael J fox is The Accidental time
traveler Marty McFly the Back to the
Future movies have become notorious for
their charm and sense of wonder this
makes it all that more surprising to
discover that during the franchise's
second installment there is a scene
displaying such a horrific accident that
the actress involved nearly died in Back
to the Future Part 2 an elaborate stun
featuring the film suffer boards
resulted in stunt professional Cheryl
Wheeler being badly injured the accident
can be spotted in the movie when a group
of bullies chases McFly through the
streets of the future town as of the
trio of Intimidators hit a ramp and are
launched into a window reeler can be
spotted missing the mark and crashing
into a concrete pillar thankfully the
stunt performer survived her injuries
but it remains one of the more
terrifying real-life mishaps to appear
in a Blockbuster
Rogue one remains one of the most
celebrated projects outside of the main
Star Wars trilogies revealing the tale
of how the Rebel Alliance came into
possession of the plans for the Imperial
Death Star the movie starred a cast of
unique characters including fan favorite
k2so performed by Alan Tudyk the bluntly
spoken Droid provides the Star Wars film
with most of the comic relief however
not many fans know that many of the
robot's most side-splitting lines were
improvised by the comedic actor in 2017
Tudyk provided an interview for the Star
Wars Twitter account answering questions
from fans he goes on to share his
favorite character moment which involved
an impromptu scene of the Droid slapping
Cassian Andor across the face and
telling him and there's a fresh one if
you mouth off again hilariously the
ad-lib moment caught actor Diego Luna
who played Andor off guard and he nearly
broke character as a result thankfully
the actor held it together as the scene
is one of the most laugh-worthy moments
in the franchise although it may be
lauded as the least loved Spider-Man
movie The Amazing Spider-Man 2 maintains
some charming moments most of the
endearing qualities from the film come
from Stars Andrew Garfield Emma Stone
who portray Peter Parker in love
interest Gwen Stacy despite their
spectacular performances however it did
not stop Emma Stone from making one of
the biggest on-screen blunders of her
career during spidey's climactic battle
with Electro Gwen insists on helping
regardless of the risk it puts on her
Garfield's character is left with no
choice but to force her to remain behind
by webbing her hand to the hood of a
police cruiser Gwen then yells
she then covers her mouth after
realizing she was revealing Spider-Man's
secret identity well according to
director Mark Webb's DVD commentary this
was a happy accident as Stone's reaction
was not scripted thankfully the seasoned
actress did not blurt out Andrew because
the unintentional moment was fittingly
placed in the film
sometimes there are movie extras so good
that they earn a credit in the film such
is the case with one of the most
forgettable Star Trek movies The Voyage
Home the film involves time traveling to
Earth in 1986 in order to bring back
humpback whales to the Future so they
can communicate with a mysterious probe
as such extras for the feature could be
plucked off the streets without wardrobe
changes or excessive makeup according to
Star trek.com One background actor never
intended on appearing on screen and only
decided to work after her vehicle was
towed by the film's production crew
appearing in a scene where the crew of
the Enterprise is searching for
directions Leila sarakayla was not
supposed to answer the actor's questions
instead the impromptu extra answered
naturally and honestly I don't know if I
know the answer to that I think it's
across the bay in Alameda however the
director thought the genuine moment was
so good he decided to keep it in the
film
one of the more ambitious and creative
Sci-Fi movies released in the 90s was
The Fifth Element starring Bruce Willis
as a taxi driver who's thrown into the
most important treasure hunt in the
Galaxy the film was the highest grossing
French film for a number of years
featuring a cast full of eclectic and
interesting characters one of the most
memorable was the villain Jean Baptiste
Emmanuel Zork portrayed by Gary Oldman
and his henchman left arm and right arm
unfortunately much like the on-screen
characters old men's actors Sidekicks
were also left out of the big boss's
nefarious plans when it came to filming
the movie in an interview with BBC Radio
1 Oldman recalled a specific moment that
caught one of his henchmen named tricky
off guard at one point zorgops to
destroy a building but fails to share
his plan with tricky unfortunately the
actor was just as naive as to what was
about to happen when the building
explodes tricky can be seen reacting
genuinely to the huge boom happening
behind him
often considered one of director Steven
Spielberg's most magical outings ET
became the highest grossing movie of all
time when it was released in 1982. while
the film has built a legacy as one of
the most beloved movies of its
generation it is also known for being
the breakout role for a young actress
named Drew Barrymore Barrymore regularly
impressed her famous director throughout
the making of the film only six years
old during the filming of E.T Barrymore
reunited with Spielberg 40 years later
on the set of her own talk show the Drew
Barrymore show during their interview
Spielberg admitted that Barrymore was
responsible for many of the iconic lines
of the film including I don't like his
feet the director also admitted that the
actress didn't even care what the film
was about meanwhile the interview
features an old Entertainment Tonight
clip of young Barrymore from 1982. with
the actress admitting that she was
acting like herself the whole time I
could act like myself the whole time on
that shoot because Gertie's sword was
like me many of the impromptu lines
would have been left on The Cutting Room
floor by other directors but Spielberg
found the magic in them and worked the
movie around Barrymore's ad-libbing
thank you
[Music]